we are told that keisha can run 170
meters in one minute this is 125 percent
of the distance that she could run in
one minute three years ago
how far could kisha run in one minute
three years ago
pause this video and see if you can
figure this out
all right now let's do it together and
my brain wants to make sure i know the
difference between three
years
ago
and today
so today
she can run
170 meters in one minute and what we
want to figure out is how much could she
run in one minute three years ago
well we know this 170 meters is 125
of the distance that she could do three
years ago
and the distance she could do three
years ago of course is 100 of the
distance that she could do three years
ago because it's the exact same distance
but i like to think in terms of
fractions so 125 percent i could rewrite
that as 125 over 100 if i divide both
the numerator and the denominator by 25
this is equivalent to 5 over 4.
so that 170 meters that is five-fourths
of what she could do three years ago and
what she could do three years ago would
be four-fourths of what she could do
three years ago because that's a hundred
percent
and so to figure out if five-fourths is
170 meters what is 4 4
let us set up a tape diagram right over
here
and i'm going to try to hand draw it as
best as i can i want to make five equal
sections and i know it's not exactly but
let's say for the sake of argument for
this video this is five equal sections
and so if we imagine that each of these
are a fourth this is five-fourths and
then this distance right over here is
going to be 170 meters that's what she
could run today and what we want to do
is figure out what is four-fourths
that's the distance that she could run
in one minute
three years ago
so this is our question mark
well to do that we just have to figure
out how big is each of these fourths
and if five of them is 170 meters well i
just have to divide 5 into
170 5 goes into 17 three times 3 times 5
is 15 subtract i get a 2 here bring down
the 0 five goes into 20 four times four
times five is 20 and it works out
perfectly
so each of these five fourths are 34
meters 34 meters 34 meters 34 meters 34
meters and 34 meters
and so the distance that she could run
three years ago is going to be four of
these fourths or four of these 34 meters
so 34
times 4
4 times 4 is 16 3 times 4 is 12 plus 1
is 13. so the mystery distance that she
could run in one minute three years ago
is
136 meters and we are done